i mean i could read our text messages
right yeah read it yeah
i mean but don't read all of them i'm
going to read all of them don't read the
the private stuff
there's no private what no there's no
private issues here you know if you want
to read the stuff hey
congratulations moving to the
neighborhood do you want to go to
mennonito farms do you want to take a
walk i hope everything's okay
that's my next question yeah why every
time i go to mendocino farms you're
there
i am maybe i'm just there's a coffee and
bobby was saying nice stuff to me but
that that you said that feels like such
a compliment i didn't even know you knew
who i was
i always see you there and i always run
may i start this
yeah cleveland i uh may i start this
i uh was addicted to you know you find
certain things
yeah and then it's like oh that's where
i go for two months yeah
so like there was a few months section
where i was there like four four times a
week
they even put my podcast on their fan of
the day board it was hello
so maybe you've seen hello cleveland
okay may i start this yes
wait hold on hold on that's not our text
messages what is that yes it it starts
here
don't go that far i want to go for it it
will cut it out if it's too long get the
date what's the date on well just go
back
to the last few months okay no i don't i
don't want to well
i'll go back for it this is my podcast
october what
26th this year yeah oh great okay
you're not going to skip anything no i'm
not i want to read it all the way
through
hello bobby can you help me shine
hello bobby can you help me shine i love
this guy and i can help you shine
hmm interesting purpose my response i
swear to god
who
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right and now there's a you know fleece
screen an essay
there's an essay i want to read this i
want to hear that me and you
shining podcast come over
have me over give me advice
let's write a sketch let's talk about
life
meet my new girlfriend make jokes about
your penis
and that get embarrassed because you
feel like a hack
is that real did i write that yeah yeah
let me buy you mendocino foreign
this is why i bought it because they
gave me free food
they don't and then you go the last
thing you say is
talk to you in december right the next
one is
that was on october 26th this is october
28th
two days later yeah and then you
this is your dad you just now
this i'm not i have not returned any of
those right your next one is your dad
giving you a text and then you're
telling me what your dad said screen
shot
right yeah i am watching bobby lee to a
lead guest role in magnum pi
he's good yeah my dad talks to me about
about seeing you on the road
and then whatever my dad mine no
response from me right
here's another one from you my response
november november 5th now
okay so about about a week and a half uh
yeah yeah i'm going
to record eight mini holiday episodes to
be released one at a time during eight
nights of hanukkah
the eight nights of tyso that's where
you've seen some of these guests
you could check i'm going to decorate my
apartment for holiday holiday style
i want them all be previous guests of my
podcast would you be one of them
come over 20 minutes in and out thinking
i'm going to record them this month
so i can edit them over thanksgiving
holiday and then no response from me
jeez november 21st right what you just
do a handshake
i mean right
here we go december 8th no response
permit would you mind for
me who you get your merchandise from not
the design but the manufacturer printer
nothing december 18th i'm feeling really
uh
i'm feeling like i'm feeling really like
i think i don't know for sure what the
feeling is i think it's an
it's embarrassed i know that's right
we're going to talk about i think i feel
like i might we might cut through all
this because it might be dead air but
no no no i just need to i just want to
read through it i feel like you
shouldn't be embarrassed no should be
embarrassing i'm embarrassed no
no no i feel like you're hanging like
that i'm embarrassed that i
i consciously made the decision to keep
talking to you
i know let me finish them all right
now that was now here we go december
18th
hey bobby you also read it like
i'm like your brother yesterday and he
filled me in
on how hard of a time you all been
having
sweet very very nice i feel bad i've
talked with you about
pod stuff and didn't pick up on any of
the obstacles you were having
good this is a very good angle good guy
that's what i liked about it the shift
because you're trying different angles
congrats on your move to
i hope you're well oh it's so sad
if you're up for getting food sometimes
mendocino farms no podcast stuff i'd
love to see you and kick it
oh i should have responded to that but i
didn't uh january 7th
next year january 7th now yeah okay
that's this is
20 20 now yeah 2020 now let's get lunch
you live so close to me right nothing
yeah january 15th
literally nothing no response oh my god
it's just yeah it's just all him
yeah that's what i love about him my
girlfriend just texted me that your
girlfriend is in here right now
here we go should i ask my girlfriend to
try and network with your girlfriend in
an attempt to get all four of us to go
to manchester united
are you sponsored by that what nothing
no response
i feel so shitty i feel bad but i'm
gonna keep reading yeah
uh january 21st and then why
clap why not the claps you know i mean
what do you call it oh like emoji like
why aren't you why
not write me back he does a clap putting
his foot down you're putting your
promotion there now so now march 7th
yeah which by the way you can people
come on this is a week before pi day
uh so january first now march 7th
bobby come take your shoes off again
next week
oh that i can't read what i just read
here okay i can't
i don't know what it is but i'm gonna
cut that out
is it something embarrassing for me or
for you it's it's embarrassing
it's it's embarrassing for you uh what
what could it be i can't do it
i don't want to do it it's funny yeah
i'll tell you later after the podcast he
has his
he hasn't saved your head oh yeah yeah
it's it's it's the conversation i don't
want to have right now i i respect that
the conversation i don't want to have
right now but you know what it is and i
don't and i want to have that
you want to cut it out then no no no no
i'll just sit now and then just cut it
out yeah
ping this all right i said um this is
okay i want to just say how rude i am
okay
oh i know why you're not saying what
you're not why you're not talking about
it right yeah that
uh no i'll just say it well no i i i'll
explain why you're not gonna say it
by just this way it's something that is
uh uh not embarrassing for either of us
i mean no but it's just it should not it
just shouldn't be talked about your god
give me the phone
it's i said oh correct
correct yeah but if you want to know
more head on over to rick glassman.com
for the answers let me finish this okay
so good call good call march 8th
want to get coffee you live so close and
i have two friends
thinking about going to the farmers
market march 8th
you just sent me a photo of mendocino
farms
hey bobby how have you ajk been
what does that mean what how ha ajk
translation rick uh asian jewish kind
you guys isolating it's scary out there
are you guys still recording checking
about you i'm scheduled with targeting
you and cabin curious about the
logistics
it just keeps going and going and going
listen you sent me photos of us
this you sent photos of us together very
sweet i feel
i want to apologize real quick okay go
ahead so you know by reading that
no honestly put your phone down by
reading all that i'd be a little less
aggressive on your apologies go ahead
i think that's the reason why i don't
respond to you i see it's that attitude
do you understand what i'm saying what
i'm dealing with interesting has it
always been like this with you two
so bobby doesn't respond to people is
that fair or is it just me
no it's i don't take it personally
across the board yeah the only person
that he responds to is paul banks
shout out to paul banks by the way we'll
put his instagram handle up here
so bobby once told me at the comedy
store i'd like to give bobby a
compliment now
nobody thinks bobby's funny i don't mean
you're not interesting
nobody finds you particularly funny and
uh you and i had a conversation
you're very funny you're one of the
funniest let's be sincere yeah if we're
gonna beat
if we're gonna [ __ ] do this yeah
you're right we're gonna [ __ ] you you're
right
it's hard to navigate it's hard to not
you have to appreciate it's hard to
navigate
over i'm literally looking at you
through a glass i understand that but